on va éviter le blabla je vais tout de
suite vous montrer un avant/après pour
vous montrer comment on peut donner un
look cinématiques à une donc là
maintenant je suis sûr vous voulez
savoir comment on fait ça on va voir ça
tout de suite après l'intro
[Musique]
salut à tous les amis c'est pourquoi
pour la chaîne explique mme encore et
aujourd'hui on va parler de look
cinématique de colorimétrie tout ça tout
ça et je vais vous montrer exactement
les réglages que j'utilise dans
l'extrait que vous avez pu le voir juste
avant mais avant il ya deux trois trucs
qui faut que je vous dise bon parce
qu'on va faire ça sans plugin sans lui
tout ça tout ça on va faire tout en
natif avec les outils de final cut et
même sur première c'est assez similaire
donc je pense que vous pourrez retrouver
vos mains je suis pas en train de dire
que les plugins ou les luttes c'est pas
bien au contraire ça peut être très
pratique ça peut faire gagner beaucoup
de temps mais avant d'aller en
télécharger en installer voire même en
acheter eh bien il faut que vous sachiez
qu'il ya plein de choses qu'on peut
faire en natif sans forcément installer
quoi que ce soit et puis aussi à prendre
en compte le fait que look cinématiques
ça veut pas forcément dire grand chose
mais ça parle à tout le monde d'où le
titre donc aujourd'hui on va parler de
traitement colorimétrique des couleurs
du des filtres en quelque sorte que j'ai
appliqué à mon image pour avoir ce rendu
là mais il faut quand même garder en
tête qu'il ya plein de choses qui
rentrent en compte c'est à dire que si
on travaille sur un blanc qui est pourri
qui est mal exposé qui a du grain ou des
choses comme ça on aura forcément
beaucoup plus de difficultés à récupérer
quoi que ce soit même avec une super
colorimétrie ce pas une méthode miracle
donc faudra garder en tête que le rendu
final dépendra certes de la post
production mais aussi des réglages et de
la captation que vous avez fait sur vos
recherches et puis dernière chose avant
de rentrer dans le vif du sujet là on
touche quand même à quelque chose de
relativement artistique à la
colorimétrie ce sont ces des choix
artistiques donc la notion de boue elle
est relativement subjective ce que moi
je trouve beau je vais vous le montrer
c'est pas forcément le cas de tout le
monde
donc voilà ça c'est dit maintenant on
s'y colle on va direct dans final cut
alors le premier truc qui doit vous
sauter aux yeux c'est que ce plan il est
de fade et c'est normal parce
qu'il a été tourné en langue ou en flat
ce que je vous encourage aussi à
utiliser si votre boîtier ou si votre
appareil photo
le permet pour faire très court parce
qu'on va pas faire une vidéo sur le blog
et le flatte le gros avantage que ça
présente c'est qu'on va pouvoir
récupérer beaucoup d'informations dans
les basses lumières et dans les hautes
lumières donc on va avoir beaucoup plus
d'infos que ça évitera d'avoir des
hautes lumières trop cramé ou des noirs
trop bouché
voilà c'est tout mais c'est absolument
pas obligatoire donc première chose
qu'on va faire c'est récupérer un petit
peu de contraste et on va aller cliquer
sur les
l'âge de couleurs ici on va cliquer sur
exposition on va venir
bc notons sombre pour les récupérer pour
récupérer ici un petit peu du noir
voilà des ondes sympa ensuite toujours
pour créer ce contraste à marc barr
remonter les hautes lumières
ici on a envoyé le t-shirt qui devient
vraiment blanc et on a quelque chose
déjà de beaucoup mieux exposés avec
quelque chose d'assez homogène quel que
soit les tons ensuite comme on est en
flammes on va venir remonter un petit
peu la saturation même beaucoup parce
qu'on avait perdu pas mal de couleur et
on va aussi baisser un petit peu la
saturation des tons intermédiaire parce
que c'est quelque chose qu'on va
retravailler après au niveau de la
couleur et les temps intermédiaires ça
correspond en gros à la couleur de peau
donc là on va les baisser un petit peu
sinon après on aura quelque chose d'un
beaucoup trop flashy de beaucoup trop
pas naturel donc là on pourrait très
bien s'arrêter là on a quelque chose
d'assez naturel on a récupéré un petit
peu toutes les couleurs on a remonté la
saturation on a géré comme il fallait la
disposition mais maintenant on va aller
un petit peu plus loin pour donner ce
petit aspect cinématiques et pour ça on
va partir sur ce qu'on appelle le tilt
d'un orange donc littéralement ça veut
dire bleu cyan et orange
on va travailler sur ces deux couleurs
je vais vous expliquer aux premières
choses à faire en validant ce réglage
qui s'appelle aux ronds de couleurs et
pour cet effet t-il en orange on va
aller pousser ici les ombres dans les
tons bleu cyan on va mettre la même
chose sur les hautes lumières voyez
quelque chose de très froid maintenant
et enfin on va remonter l'iton
intermédiaire donc obligée de tout à
l'heure c'est souvent la peau vers le
orange pour faire un pop est un petit
peu tout ça alors pourquoi le tilène
orange et bien tout simplement c'est pas
un effet de mode
c'est que la peau humaine se situe dans
les tons orange quelle que soit la
couleur de peau bas tout est sur des
dégradés d'orange plus ou moins sombres
ou plus ou moins claires et il se trouve
que la couleur complémentaire du orange
c'est le bleu cyan donc en fait un
travaillant sur ces deux couleurs en
mettant les ombres et les clairs en bleu
et les intermédiaires en orange on va
arriver à avoir un contraste et à faire
ressortir notamment les visages et les
couleurs de peau ce qui nous ajoute un
deuxième contraste le premier il a été
fait avec la lumière
les basses lumières les hautes lumières
le deuxième contraste ici se fera avec
la couleur ensuite on peut aller ici
réchauffer un petit peu l'atmosphère en
monte à un petit peu la température
puisque là c'était encore un peu trop
bleu à mon goût pour pour le général
alors vous remarqué que moi je travaille
sur un calque des fait sur un agent
payeur
je vous encourage à aller voir la vidéo
qui se situe juste ici qui vous explique
comment installer et comment l'utiliser
mais vous pouvez aussi très bien faire
directement sur l'orge alors derniers
réglages de couleur on va aller d'un les
courbes de teintes et de saturation qui
vont nous permettre de changer un petit
peu certaines couleurs pour donner un
look un peu plus signer alors ici je
vais aller sur la courbe teinte contre
tintin et moi ce que je veux faire c'est
rendre ce ciel qui est un peu bleu
marine
je veux le rendre turquoise comme vous
voyez là si je vais trop dans les
extrêmes c'est pas joli mais en montant
un petit peu ici je me retrouve avec un
ciel qui est un peu plus turquoise un
peu moins bleu foncé et voilà c'est le
rendu que j'avais envie d'avoir
et là encore on va travailler ici sur la
courbe teinte contre saturation pour
avoir quelque chose d'un peu plus
chaleureux
on va aller ici aussi travaillé sur ces
bleus la pop
on va booster la saturation de ce bloc
on a rendu un petit peu de turquoise
vous voyez que si je baisse j'ai plus
rien et là hop je peux remonter alors je
peux utiliser aussi la pipette pour
sélectionner leur la couleur que je veux
mais là pour le coup je sais où ça se
trouve
et enfin on va descendre ici toujours
pour travailler sur ce orange sur la
courbe orange contre saturation qui
servent surtout à travailler sur les
tons orange et là je vais mettre un
petit coup en dessous pour avoir quelque
chose de plus lisse de plus de plus
propre hop est ici de la même façon on
va booster un petit peu pour donner un
ton plus frais à ces petits visages qui
était sympa mais qu'on voulait encore
plus sympa et enfin pour finir la petite
cerise sur le gâteau pour donner ce look
cinématiques et ben on va mettre les
bandes noires de cinéma c'est l'effet
les torts box qu'on va les chercher dans
les effets et qu'on va revenir appliqué
ici directement soit sur le jazzman
players que je recommande soit sur le
ruck on va choisir 2,35
quel format cinéma
et on a notre look cinématiques
comme vous pouvez le voir ici alors on
pourrait même pousser un petit peu plus
en rajoutant l'effet net tu es pour
mettre un tout petit peu de netteté en
plus sur un petit vieux voilà c'est pas
indispensable mais ça peut faire la
différence ça se verra pas beaucoup mais
vous vous le verrez donc ça sera plutôt
cool et déjà rien qu'en en gérant
correctement l'exposition avec les tons
sombres les tons clairs pour récupérer
le maximum d'informations et en donnant
ce petit côté tilène orange derrière on
va avoir quelque chose qui va avoir un
air beaucoup plus cinématiques que à une
prise brut tout simplement et amusez
vous regardez la plupart des films que
vous voyez au cinéma ils ont ce look
t-il en orange vous regardez la peau des
personnages légèrement orangé les
tensions dans les tons clairs sont
légèrement bleutée pas toujours mais a
assez souvent c'est une technique est
vraiment très employé au cinéma donc du
coup ça adonne vraiment cet effet
cinématiques sur les vidéos et voilà les
amis c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu ça
faisait longtemps que vous me demandiez
comment je fais ma colorimétrie et c'est
donc la plupart du temps j'utilise ça de
temps en temps j'utilise des luttes
également mais ça on en parlera après
cette lutte plugin est ce que c'est bien
de les utiliser ou pas lesquels il faut
utiliser mais ça sera pour une prochaine
vidéo n'hésitez pas à mettre dans les
commentaires aussi vos techniques de
colorimétrie ce que vous utilisez pour
vos vidéos ça pour moi ça m'intéresse
toujours la prendre des nouvelles choses
bien entendu on n'oublie pas le
traditionnel coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe en dessous
de cette vidéo si vous n'êtes pas déjà
abonné vous pouvez cliquer sur le bouton
ça fait plaisir il ya de plus en plus de
monde et c'est vraiment cool
et puis puis la cloche aussi si vous
voulez être notifiée 2 toutes les
sorties de vidéos un lacet l'été c'est
un peu plus calme mais il y en a quand
même qui va en sortir
et puis ben moi je vous dis comme
d'habitude rester curieux et à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
ouais alors la tendinite 1
ça commence à ça serait pas gentiment
mais mais ça pique encore un petit peu
là je suis fou hein on n'a pas idée
souvent une tendinite comme ça c'est un
franchement quelle idée en tournant des
vidéos en plus tendinite
le mec tu gens
[Musique]